NO HARM DONE
AND JOHANSSON SCORED A GREAT
BACKHANDED GOAL IN THAT GAME
AND THE CAPITALS HAD AINSIDE .
HE GOT TO  ARE LOOKING AT AN
OFF-SITE POSSIBLY.Y.  BLEW A WHD
THAT ALLOWED PALMIERI TO STEP
INSIDE.
BUT THERE WERE TWO GUYS IN
REFEREE.
WATCH HIS ST RANGERS HERE.
ON
AND THAT IS TH A  THE BEST
SAVE SO FAR.. SHOT OFF THE
CROSSBAR RATTLES AROUND AND IN E
CAPITALS -- HE CAN'T
ALL OVER THE PLACE
BIT OF A WIDE-OPEN GAME.
>> Joe: WILL IT LOOKS GREAT.AND
>> Craig: THAT WAS ONE OF THE
BEST  . HAS.
HE'S HAD A GREAT SEASON.
>> Joe: SEEING EACH
OTHER AND THEN LAST YEAR IT WAS
ROTATION PLAY OFF OF RICOCHET C.
I AM SURE OF ONE ANSWER BUT I P
GREAT KICK OUTET WIDE
AT IT HITS HIM RIGHT IN THE
KNEECAP AND GOES RIGHT
THE REBOUNEFFORT 3-1
LEAD.
THE FIRSS WITH THE MINUTES 45
SECONDS REMAIN IN THE THIRD.VE
THE ISLANDERS ARE CRUISING.
>> Joe: BACKHAND HERE AND